Syria has been devastated by conflict
Millions have died or been displaced
since an uprising against the rule of
Bashar al-assad began 12 years ago
despite their losses people say they
have not abandoned their cause
I lost my house and my little sister in
the bombardment of Eastern Aleppo I also
lost my leg and was hospitalized for
weeks we were simply asking for the
basic human rights but instead of
listening to us the Syrian regime chose
to wipe out the country
the UN estimates more than 400 000
people have been killed since the
conflict erupted with over 13 million
fleeing as refugees or becoming
internally displaced
they say that despite their desperate
situation they remain hopeful for a
brighter future for the Next Generation
the people here prefer to live in these
harsh conditions rather than under
Assad's rule we have the saying we
should perish but the Syrian regime
won't rule us
many still hold that the years of
struggle were necessary no matter the
consequences
believes that what Assad viewed as the
Rebellion against the state was in fact
unavoidable
given Assad's own abuse of power
stopping now is never an option the
uprising exposed the true face of the
International Community as well as the
true face of this regime if you ask me
if I would have chosen this path 12
years ago I would have said absolutely
yes even though we lost so many
companions along the way their
sacrifices will not go in vain if we
stop now our children will pay a far
greater price
in spite of the absence of long-term
Solutions alhamdul aspires to a peaceful
life for his children
Sirens are honoring the 12th anniversary
of their Uprising a day that has come to
represent hope and resilience for them
although knowing that the road ahead
would be long and difficult they said
that they will never give up until they
fulfill their goals